Speaker 1: I'm going to go to Eric from Cancun,
and I'm doing this with significant
trepidation. It's been a while since
we heard from Eric from Cancun. Eric,
welcome. What do you have for me today?
Eric from Cancun. You are on the air. Welcome.
And absolutely last opportunity for
Erik from Cancun, who I know has an
agenda every time he speaks to me.
But we can't hear. He's not speaking.
Speaker 2: Hello? Hello, baby.
Speaker 1: Eric. Welcome. Welcome,
welcome. Sorry, amigo.
Speaker 2:
I'm sorry my leg wasn't working. I feel sad
right now. I made a proposal. Some call because
it seems I've seen the comments of our calls
and any are asking if I could be a regular and
that if we can make a phone call, I can give
you the whole cake instead of just crumbs,
slices and pieces of my mind. And what do you say?
Speaker 1: You know, Eric, I don't know that my
mind can handle more ideas than what I get from
you in the short snippets. I don't. I don't know
that I could if I would be in recovery
mode constantly from your high level ideas.
Speaker 2: And in that case, I'm just going
to ask you, is your child a boy or a girl?
Speaker 1: Is my YouTube channel a
boy or a girl? Is that your question?
Speaker 2: And now in is your
do you have a daughter or son?
Speaker 1: Oh, sorry. I thought you were asking
me the gender of my. My channel. My child.
No. A Sunni-Shia issue now, Nina.
Speaker 2: And we both eat that.
And I'm very happy for you.
Speaker 1: Eric. That means a lot to me. I
appreciate that. Do you have any parenting tips.
Speaker 2: And how would
you do the humor like in the style of parenting?
I can explain it first. You get a three then like
a like a princess. You got to give with anything
you want to have the best, like from 0 to 5 years
old. From 5 to 10 years old. You got to be
just go through there like a worker so you
don't spoil her, because if you support her, then
she will learn how to manipulate you and mothers.
Right. And you'll get to give them
responsibility. So she knows where the boundaries.
Speaker 1: Right. All right. The Himalayan style
of parenting. That's very interesting, Eric.
Speaker 2: Then from 10 to 15, you go with
him more like an adult that you get to express
yourself and have your own ideas. But don't
criticize us too much because then she will never
want to tell you anything, because you will feel
that you will not listen to her. Right. And then
from 15 to 22, you go to current as an equal. Then
you are in the same level. Do you? Completely.
Speaker 1: I understand perfectly. And
Eric, just by the way, is it okay that I'm
feeding a two month old pizza? Is that is that
allowed in the Himalayan style of parenting?
Speaker 2: And I. I haven't seen
it. But even outside of that,
I don't think so. Maybe around four years old.
Speaker 1: Okay, very good. No pizza until age
four. Eric Mujiasih maggot ass. Yes.
I really appreciate your call today.
Speaker 2: And so I hope
you reconsider it someday.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you very much.
There is Eric from Cancun. Absolutely shot
out of a can. And I genuinely thought he asked
me the gender of my YouTube channel. I mean,
gender is so big these days. Like, I don't know,
maybe that's the thing. My channel has a gender.